i hated that job you know because i
probably made 50 to 100 phone calls a
day
but when it came time five years later
to raise money for my film my feature
pete the first chapter of your book
transitions a director's journey and
motivational handbook
starts with how to quit
so what is this and why is that
important to start the book
so
you know the one of the things that i
wanted to keep in mind with the book was
that
i don't want to be prescriptive in in
saying this is the way you have to do it
and i also didn't want to be
um
overwhelming to the reader in a sense of
like you got to figure out you've got to
know what you want to do
every you know nook and cranny of your
career needs needs to be decided and
then
just attack it because i know that it
can take people various amounts of time
to figure out
what their what their voice might be
what their sensibility might be
what their appetite for whatever
different position you might seek in the
industry
requires of you and so
i wanted to
in the beginning um
speak about curiosity and how
much of a of a
benefit or a plus it is to have that um
because if you're not curious i think
you start to become
a little too cemented in what you think
works and does not work and it's
constantly evolving
and in route to figuring out what you
want to do specifically you're going to
have to quit and so i wanted to
hopefully
present that to the reader in a way that
it's not a derogatory word to quit um in
fact when you choose to quit it's an
empowering thing so if you are walking
down a road of let's say you're you're
editing and you're like uh editing's not
for me um and you pivot from editing to
writing or editing to producing that
that quitting can be a positive thing so
it's kind of
my opportunity to rebrand uh
the energy around the word quitting
and is there quitting with finesse and
quitting
with burning your bridges
that's a great question i think that
um
you can definitely quit with finesse um
i think when it's clear what your goals
are then you know
i think i maybe found the right word or
another word for it which is a pivot i
think i think quitting can be just a
pivot um but i also think you can burn
you can end up burning bridges if you do
it uh if you don't dismount gracefully
you know what i mean so i think
the idea is to not burn any bridges
because you never know
when you're going to run into people
again
and i think a lot of what we do in the
industry is
built upon relationships so
um
burning them down is probably not going
to be in your favor but sometimes that
can be hard not to
right because i'm thinking if if let's
suppose there's personality differences
but it's better to as i like how you say
it dismount gracefully
um
that might be difficult and especially
if there's an ego at the top and so
egos at the top tend to know each other
and could make phone calls so yeah just
how you
dismount and making sure no one's pride
is hurt that's a difficult thing in any
industry i would imagine
yeah it is i feel like you know another
thing that i've i've come to
try and add to
my process it's like
certain relationships are going to be
and by i'm speaking more specifically to
like um
positions on a crew are going to be
contentious by virtue of the fact of
what each position is
empowered to do
right so like an easy example is like a
cinematographer wants more you know
equipment to beautifully capture the
show and a producer is
wanting to get the best look
for the least amount of money and so
if we if these two parties know that
then they can already accept that it's
going to be a lot of no's and a lot of
whys and a lot of you know
seemingly contentious exchanges it but
if you know it's going to be like that
you can get past that and kind of just
have the conversation you need to or
maybe find a way to embrace it with
humor because we're all just doing what
we
i hopefully you know we're all just
doing what the job requires of us like
if i if i want another take
at a scene
hopefully the actors know that i'm not
doing it you know
for
um any reason other than i'm trying to
get the best
out of this moment you know
but then on the flip if an actor feels
like they don't have another take to
give and and they think that we've got
it
and
you know it seems like
they're really not willing to do another
one
you know what i have to make a decision
on my end too and so it's
always this kind of
frequent navigation
of the interpersonal dynamics that you
have to find finesse in
and i think maybe as people get older
they realize okay i need to do
the two weeks notice or even a month or
you know have the talk and let them know
you know i'm i'm going to be leaving but
i think when we're younger and i'm
speaking from my own experience there
are times when you just go okay cool
it's lunch time i won't be coming back
and and you think that okay i'm 21 it's
not going to matter right but maybe just
you know don't take that interning job
it's not something i probably could have
taken at that age but if you can't
stay with it you know and and you know a
lot of times
the the jobs we come across that we
don't
enjoy
oftentimes like
there are periods of time right like
like it might be a three-month
commitment or it's the duration of this
film you know sometimes it's can you get
through it is there anything else you
can learn
outside of you know the thing that you'd
rather not be dealing with
um
you know can you learn the inner
workings of how
a film is produced while being in that
office that has a few people that aren't
your type of people
you know what i mean like can you can
you find the the value to take away from
it um a lot of times it's
reconfiguring your perspective to
get something
guaranteed to propel you forward
right and did anyone question you about
that uh chapter or did people praise you
like well that's great that's a great
way to start a book about it yeah i
think people i think there's a sense of
relief and i hope there's a sense of
relief you know for people who read it
and they're like okay yeah that's uh
i can i don't i'm not about to read a
book that's going to tell me
you know here's what you need to do and
blah blah blah it's going to help me
find
uh help me develop some tools
through which to
employ as i move toward finding my path
so the response has been great
i think it sets the tone that it's going
to be
more reality based rather than
um
you know just i don't know all these
cliches that you hear for years but that
you know that okay stuff is temporary
and you know it may not always be a fit
and
that's okay and
you may not be able to fix it right
right
so
do you think that there's a time limit
on how long to stay with the job now i
realize it's different because tv
directing and it's
short-term projects usually but
yeah that's a great question i mean
i guess
so
is there a time limit for how long to
stay with a job you know i feel like a
lot of what
happens in i'm gonna take film and tv
and try and marry you know those the
types of jobs that people have a lot of
times they're
they're
p they're freelance driven or they're
kind of periodic so they kind of have
their own time limits where
you know
if you're on a if you're editing a film
you know it's i don't know why i keep
using editing but if you're editing a
film it's
12 to 18 weeks of your life you know and
then you can move to the next one
um tv show
you know nine months maybe fewer uh if
you're a producer
you know that project is gonna
project may never go you know or it may
it may be a small window in time and
then maybe
you didn't have a good time on it but
they make a sequel and you
back out of it you know because you want
to have
whatever peace of mind you're looking
for so i feel like we have a unique
opportunity in this creative space to
not be married to anything too long
so you can find a way to withdraw or not
continue
without having to quit
um
but you know if and when that thing that
situation arises uh it's it's really
measuring
what's the what's the real benefit i
mean i will say if there's questions of
of like mental health if there's
questions of like you know
it's just
an improper situation then by all means
like
talk to the proper people and and
withdraw yourself from anything that's
you know
not good for you um
but you know i think
finding
that being too ideal
about how the work experience should be
can also leave one you know
missing out from the benefits that they
could take from a particular job because
i can tell you like if i go through the
jobs that i've had over
you know my career
not many of them were awesome but
you know what i mean but a lot but i but
they're like i can always go back and
say oh i learned that thing from that
job and then who knew that
four years later i'd be able to take
that thing
and and turn it into something that
powered what i was doing
one of my first jobs out of college was
um
you know working for a company that
would kind of soon be over
taken by imdb
um but this was a company that you had
to pay for the information that is
available for free now
um and i had to call you know i'd read
the trades hollywood reporter variety um
i'd look at the film markets me fed
american film market whatever it was and
i would then call and say oh it says
that you
bought the rights to this book is it
true are you making this movie what
status is it in when it might you begin
shooting it whatever and i hated that
job you know because i probably made 50
to 100 phone calls a day
um but when it came time five years
later to raise money for my film my
feature
i built a muscle up of like i can talk
to anybody you know because it's just a
conversation
until they tell me no i don't
want to invest in your project
i have no problem following up
because that's you know just kind of
this thing that it was the byproduct of
what i had done
begrudgingly for two years
that's fascinating was that the book
that was in blockbuster
you know i well it was called baseline
studio systems and i don't know
i think it was all
they i mean i imagine they probably had
some physical
resource that you got um but i believe
it existed online and then you just
subscribed to it and got whatever you
got but that's how that i mean i dealt
with one little process of it i don't
even know what
people got on the other end of their of
their payment
right oh that's fascinating so then
you'd had people hang up and and you'd
already sort of been
you know that the hazing of any
telemarketer you probably already yeah
okay that's gonna happen you know
fine you know uh oh you don't
you know because
they're and then they're on the flip
there will be people would be like i'm
calling for my 900th attempt to update
this record because after x amount of
time we're going to
check to see like should we make this a
a
like a dead record
or is it active
you know and so you're calling people
and it's like the production company
somewhere in north carolina and it's the
same guy you've called eight times and
it's like hey how you been and they're
telling you a little bit more about the
trials and tribulations of making the
film and you know you're building these
relationships in a in a weird way that's
fascinating wow and so that that must
have really helped i'm sure yeah then
you then you're not scared yeah yeah
and just wrapping up so it sounds like
with most jobs if i were an hr manager
and i looked at a resume with all these
different projects i'd be like oh wow
you've you've jumped around a bit but in
the film industry it sounds like that's
a plus yeah i mean i you know
i would i imagine so i've been very kind
of tunnel driven with with
my career pursuits but i do know like
friends that i've had in advertising in
the commercial world
it was
shared with me that it almost looked bad
if you stayed somewhere longer than two
to three years because
then
i guess what they were saying is that it
looks like you're stagnant
or it looks like um you know
you're not seeking to try new ideas and
then communicate in a different way or
you're not well sought after
you know so there's all these little
each industry kind of has its own
um
take
on
the activity of a resume